et notre invité ce matin c'est Franck
papazan bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes le coprésident du
Conseil de coordination des
organisations arméniennes de France
merci d'avoir accepté cette interview
avec à mes côté Stéphane Vernet de West
France bonjour Stéphane bonjour bonjour
on va évidemment parler de la situation
dans le haut cararabach en assiste
depuis plusieurs jours un exode massif
des Arméniens de ce territoire après des
attaques de l'Azerbaïdjan qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire ce matin de la
situation sur place de ce que vous en
savez bah il ne reste quasiment plus
d'habitants on a du mal à évaluer le nom
mais ils étaient 120000 il y a encore
une semaine ils sont 1500 peut-être
encore
aujourd'hui les Arméniens du hautkarabak
ont été victimes d'une épuration
ethnique il faut le dire il faut que le
monde ait le courage de qualifier cette
vaste opération menée par l'Azerbaïdjan
pour éliminer déraciner leur arabar et
éliminer la population arménienne du
okarabak qui avait plusieurs moyens de
le faire ils ont choisi de la terroriser
ils ont choisi de leur faire peur ils
ont choisi de créer les conditions qui
leur permettent de choisir entre la
valise ou le
cercueil vous avez connaissance de de
d'exaction d'exécution son des massacres
parce que il se dit beaucoup de choses
le terme dépuration ethnique il est très
fort il y a un déplacement massif qui
est très réel mais est-ce qu'on sait ce
qui se passe vraiment dans le dans dans
le dans le territoire c'est un processus
qui a démarré en 2020 avec la guerre des
44 jours au cours de laquelle
l'Azerbaïjan a utilisé des armes
interdites des dromes assassins des
bombes à sousmunition des bombes au
phosphore blanc et il y a eu 5000 morts
5000 morts les les sur 120000 habitants
c'est considérable 5000 morts en en
rapport avec la population c'est
considérable 70 % du territoire avait
été conquis en 2020 et il y a eu un
processus de de terreur qui a été mis en
place puisquen 2021 l'Azerbaïdjan a
également occupé une petite partie du
territoire de la République d'Arménie en
violant toutes les lois internationales
et puis elle a entamé des guerres
éclaires contre l'Arménie contre la
République d'Arménie et puis le 19
septembre on a bien vu qu'il y a une
guerre qui a fait 300 morts 200 blessés
et 105 disparus dans un temps très très
court en 24 he et là maintenant est-ce
que vous avez des des témoignages
fiables c'est très difficile de savoir
ce qui se passe sur place ou ce qui
s'est passé on a pas de témoignage
direct mais on a des témoignages
indirect et on sait que des des corps
ont été mutilés des personnes vivantes
ont été égorgé en étant égorgé les
personnes continuent à bouger euh donc
il y a eu effectivement ce ce genre de
de pratiques qui ne sont pas
surprenantes de la part de l'Azerbaïdjan
qui cultive une haine d'État et un
racisme d'État envers les Arméniens il
faut quand même rappeler également ça
c'est assez particulier que depuis le 12
décembre 2022 jusqu'au mois de septembre
mi-septembre l'Azerbaïdjan a exercé un
blocus contre le haut karabak c'estàdire
que la seule route qui reliait l'Arménie
au karabak était bloqué rien ne sortait
rien ne rentrait à la Chine et en
réalité l'objectif de l'Azerbaïjan c'est
de mettre en place un génocide par la
famine Louis Moreno Ocampo que vous
connaissez j'imagine qui a été le
premier procureur général de la Cour
pénale internationale a rendu un rapport
très clair il va venir en France au mois
DEP au mois d'octobre a rendu un rapport
très clair dans lequel il disait le
processus
génocidaire mené par l'Azerbaïjan est en
cours contre les Arméniens du hakarabakh
je voudrais vous rappeler également donc
l'Azerbaïdjan nen a que faire des
injonctions internationales puisqu'au
mois de février la Cour internationale
de Justice a exigé de l'Azerbaïdjan
qu'elle ouvre le couloir elle n'a pas
écouté à la demande de la France et à
deux reprises cet été le Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU a été
convoqué de la même manière il a été
demandé à l'Azerbaïjan d'ouvrir mais
l'Azerbaïjan donc la communauté
internationale est impuissante si
l'Azerbaïdjan n'est pas forcé par la par
une opération militaire de sauvegarde et
de sauvetage du peuple arménien
évidemment qu'elle ne bougera pas
aujourd'hui la communauté l'Azerbaïjan a
compris que la communauté internationale
faisait preuve de l'âacheter on va
revenir là-dessus justement à commencer
par la France le rôle de la France
puisque Catherine colon la ministre des
Affaires étrangères pardon est en
Arménie aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est un
bon
signal je je veux dire que le Président
de la République Emmanuel Macron a donné
le ton et effectivement la France est un
des rares pays à se mobiliser pour
l'Arménie et pour le haut karabak je
l'ai dit si les réunions du Conseil de
sécurité ont eu lieu et si l'affaire est
allée au Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
c'est parce que la France l'a demandé
effectivement Catherine Colonna Emmanuel
Macron ont condamné l'Azerbaïdjan et
condamné l'agression de l'Azerbaïjan
maintenant ce que nous demandons
clairement à la France puisque nous
sommes français vous dites sa visite
aujourd'hui c'est c'est quandme c'est
pas trop tard ah ben c'est dire ça vient
tard mais des choses ont été faites
avant aujourd'hui c'était déjà rendu en
Arménie en avril non mais il y a eu tout
un tout un une activité diplomatique de
la France en soutien à l'Arménie au
carab prise opposition officielle très
très clair très clair mais en fait ça
n'est pas
suffisant nous nous sommes nous
enregistrons avec satisfaction
l'engagement de la France au côté de
l'Arménie et d au Kabak mais ça n'est
pas suffisant dans ce cont pourrait
devrait faire de plus selon vous
aujourd'hui écoutez aujourd'hui vu le
contexte V tout ce qui s'est passé vu
les demandes répétées de la communauté
internationale de la France à l'époque
pour l'ouverture du couloir de la Chine
vu vu que la France a condamné
l'Azerbaïdjan a pointé du doigt
l'Azerbaïjan comme étant l'agresseur et
que l'Azerbaïjan en réalité continue
continue vous dites vous-même ça suffit
pas ça ne suffit donc la France doit
prendre des décisions qu'elle peut
prendre elle-même lesquell alors seul
j'ai demandé déjà l'expulsion de
l'ambassadrice d'Azerbaidjan de France
et de tous les diplomates azerbaidjanais
il faut fermer l'ambassade d'Azerbaidjan
en France ça n'est pas possible que la
France garde sur son territoire une
représentation diplomatique d'un état
criminel qui n'écoute pas les
injonctions internationales qui ne
respectent pas les ça peut être utile
dans cette période de crise de garder un
lien diplomatique avec l'Azerbaidjan
mais non parce qu'en réalité le dialogue
ave Ren avec Aliev ne ser rien Aliev est
un dictateur il n'est pas dans le
dialogue il est dans l'exécution de son
plan et le plan d'aliief est concerté
avec Erdogan le président turc c'est un
plan panturque pour éliminer l'Arménie
et le ha cararabak et donc il est
important aujourd'hui que la France se
fasse respecter parce que en réalité
avec cette démarche et bien on inverse
un peu le rapport de force parce que
éliminer toute présence diplomatique de
l'Azerbaïdjan en France c'est gênant
pour l'Azerbaïdjan deuxièmement j'ai
demandé le gel des avoirs de la famille
alief en France ça c'est possible c'est
c'est bien sûr ça a été fait pour
d'autres chefs d'État notamment des
chefs d'État africains pourquoi ça ne
serait pas possible et alors moi j'ai
aucune aucune idée de de ce que possède
le président de l'Azerbaïdjan en France
qu'est-ce que ça représente beaucoup de
bien beaucoup de bien des compt en
banque des biens des immeubles il faut
il faut les les mettre ça c'est un moyen
de pression efficace c'est un moyen de
pression efficace troisièmement fermer
les groupes parlementaires les groupes
d'amitier France azerbaïjan on l'a
demandé ça a été fait à l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat il y a un groupe
France euh Azerbaidjan Caucase euh
France Caucase pardon France Caucase
demande que l'Azerbaïdjan soit extraite
éliminé de ce groupe France Caucase je
crois que les choses sont en cours il
faut taper du point sur la table c'est
aujourd'hui la France est un grand pays
vous avez eu des contacts au Sénat hier
Gérard Larché dans son discours de
président du Sénat nouvellement réélu il
a réaffirmer son soutien euh à l'Arménie
c'est important le rôle de cette
diplomatie parlementaire c'est très
important aujourd'hui on a le soutien de
tous les groupes parlementaires et à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat qui
ont bien compris effectivement que il
fallait soutenir l'Arménie et les
Arméniens du karabak et qu'il fallait
condamner l'Azerbaïdjan et condamner
également les visés panturc du tandem
Erdogan
Ali sur l'IDE financière un mot peutre
St le Catherine Colona donc la ministre
des Affaires étrangères française
annoncé un une aide financière
supplémentaire de 7 millions d'euros à
l'Arménie la semaine dernière ça
représente un triplement de l'aide
humanitaire rapporté par la France
depuis depuis le début de l'année est-ce
que c'est suffisant et est-ce que
d'autres pays de l'Union européenne ont
la même le même type de démarche
franchement je dis merci 7 millions 7
millions 120000 personnes déplacées qui
va falloir reloger qui va don qui
n'auront plus de travail qui ont plus de
métier qui ont plus de quoi nourrir
leurs enfants qui n'ont plus de quoi
envoyer leurs enfants à l'école 7
millions mais merci quand même mais en
réalité de quoi parle-t-on vous demandez
combien c'est 12 et demi depuis le début
de l'anné très bien très bien bien sûr
mais bien sûr merci je le dis encore une
fois mais je crois qu'il faut qu'il y a
une prise de
conscience de la communauté
internationale c'est le cas ou pas
est-ce que d'autr d'autres
pays je sais que le Président de la
République Emmanuel Macron travaille
pour pour rallier d'autres États
européens à la cause je sais que
l'Allemagne a fait un pas supplémentaire
effectivement voilà c'est un travail
important à mener parce qu'en fait
l'Europe et on a vu de quelle manière
ursuna van derlen la président de la
Commission européenne se comporte avec
le président Aliev qu'elle considère
comme un partenaire exemplaire et loyal
alors justement parce qu'il a un contrat
qui a été signé entre l'Union européenne
et l'Azerbaïdjan sur la question du gaz
vous demandez que ce contrat soit rompu
on imagine écoutez je demande que
l'Europe retrouve ses esprits elle les a
perdus avec l' elle a perdu ses valeurs
elle a perdu ses esprits elle a perdu sa
force l'Europe est cliente
elle paye pour avoir ce gaz et donc
c'est l'Europe qui est en position de
force par rapport à l'Azerbaidjan pour
vous elle est pas dépendante du gaz elle
est en position de force mais demain on
peut trouver d'autres la France par
exemple n'achète pas de gaz à
l'Azerbaïdjan la France a trouvé
d'autres d'autres partenaires pour pour
le gaz aujourd'hui comme l'Azerbaïjan ne
fournit pas ne produit pas assez de gaz
pour fournir l'Europe vous savez ce
qu'elle fait elle achète du gaz à la
Russie et c'est le gaz russe qui est
fourni en Europe mais tout le monde le
sait j'ai eu cette conversation avec le
président de la République vous dites
que c'est une façon de détourner le
blocus mais c'est un c'est c'est une
rupture de l'embargo en fait c'est une r
et le président de la République
lui-même vous en a parlé tout le monde
est au courant en Europe tous les
dirigeants sont au courant en Europe et
aujourd'hui continue d'importer du gaz
russe VI l'azeran une hypocrisie
c'est-à-dire au lieu d'acheter que l'
achète directement le gaz russe à 100
elle achète le gaz russe via
l'Azerbaïdjan à 150 c'est-à-dire que
l'Europe enrichit et la Russie et
l'Azerbaïjan et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle l'Europe a un moyen de
pression beaucoup plus fort que celui de
Bakou envers l'Europe en réalité c'est
la raison pour laquelle l'Europe doit
retrouver sa force et s c'est un échec
pour l'Europe ce qui est en train de se
passer éche c'est c'est inadmissible
c'est honteux l'Europe c'est déshonoré
Ursula V derleyen la président de la
commission qui hélas va être reçu par le
parti Renaissance au campus à Bordeaux
samedi hélas va être reçu porte une
lourde responsabilité dans cette affaire
ça vous dit à Renaissance qu'il faut pas
la recevoir signal en honteux je trouve
que c'est honteux pour renaissance de
recevoir Ursula van derleyen alors
qu'elle est sous les feux de l'actualité
aujourd'hui dans cette affaire elle
porte une lourde responsabilité on peut
avoir des contrat avec l'Azerbaïjan mais
on peut éviter tout de même de dire que
l'Azerbaïdjan est un partenaire loyal et
de on peut avoir des discussions avec
l'azerbajan et d'ailleurs être client de
l'Azerbaïjan c'est lui c'est ce donner
des droits également c'est on peut
également ne pas être client de
n'importe quel type d'État on doit
utiliser ce statut pour négocier un
comportement de l'Azerbaïdjan pour
négocier avec l'Azerbaïjan est-ce que
c'est pas un difficile aussi pour
l'Union européenne pour la communauté
internationale d'intervenir à partir du
moment où le haut Caraba est un ire qui
n'est pas reconnu mais on dit pas que la
pratique politique est facile mais si on
n'est pas à la hauteur on ne s'engage
pas en politique c'est aujourd'hui il y
a une crise extrêmement grave on a parlé
d'épuration ethnique luisocampo
morenoocampo parle de génocide Vincent
Ducla qui qui qui est actuellement sur
les plateaux spécialiste des génocides
dit que c'est la continuité du génocide
de 1915 et comment vous intervenez sur
un territoire qui officiellement en
droit international appartient à
l'Azerbaïdjan que peut faire la
communauté internationale madame madame
je suis très étonné par votre question
quand il y a 120000 Arméniens sur le
plan
humanitaire qui sont qui risquent un
génocide qui faut fa est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres interventions possibles que sur
le plan humanitaire question ça fait
longtemps que la communauté
internationale aurait dû envoyer des
forces d'interposition des forces de
paix des casques bleus pour aller sauver
cette population on le voit bien la
Azerbaidjan est un pays haineux c'est
une haine d'État un racisme d'État et
d'ailleurs on voit bien de quelle
manière l'ambassadrice d'Azerbaïdjan à
Paris sur les plateaux déverse son
mensonge d'État c'estàd elle dit ils
sont partis de leur plein gré mais de
quoi parle-t-on en fait on a terrorisé
cette population on lui a fait peur on a
massacré on a massacré cette population
et puis on on dit elle est partie de son
plein gré on vous entend et on vous
comprend parfaitement par contre vous
pouz comprendre que le la situation
elle-même peut être difficile à
percevoir pour nous d'ici notamment moi
j'ai j'ai j'ai compris que début 2022 le
Premier ministre arménien lui-même avait
reconnu la souveraineté de l'Azerbaïjan
sur le haut-karabach pourquoi est-ce
qu'il a est-ce que est-ce que quelle est
le la position aujourd'hui du
gouvernement arménien lui-même par
rapport à par rapport au conflit en
cours l'Arménie est coincé aujourd'hui à
l'ouest par la Turquie à l'est par
l'Azerbaïjan donc ça veut dire que
gouvernement arménien n'avait pas
d'autre choix que de reconnaître cette
souveraineté c'est ça que vous êtes en
train non je pense que le gouvernement
arménien n'aurait pas dû reconnaître la
souveraineté de l'Azerbaïjan sur le haut
karabak pour moi c'est une erreur pour
moi c'est un une manifestation de
faiblesse à laquelle nous n'adhérons pas
nous ne voulons pas adhérer et oui c'est
ce qui explique nos questions est-ce que
vous avez l'impression finalement que le
gouvernement arménien a sacrifié le haut
carabak pour protéger l'Arménie et pour
éviter que l'Azerbaïjan n'envahisse son
territoire vous savez char
pour éviter la guerre on a choisi le
déshonneur on aura les deux et on aura
les deux en fait on aura la guerre et on
aura le
déshonneur donc il y a quand même aussi
une forme de lcheté de la part de
l'Arménie ou pas je je je non je dirais
pas non je dirais pas qu'il y aurait y a
une femme de lâcheté de la part de
l'Arménie l'Arménie est dans une
situation extrêmement délicate je pense
que laissons l'Arménie tranquille pour
l'instant est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
craignez que ce qui se passe s'étende et
que la nie soit également attaqué par
l'azerjan c'est pas que je le crains
c'est Aliev le président azerbaïdjanais
le dictateur mais non mais il en parle
depuis 2020 c'est-à-dire que après la
défaite de 2020 en fait le président
azerbaidjanais a multiplié les
déclarations et d'ailleurs elles sont
diffusées dans les médias il a multiplé
déclarations en disant que l'Arménie
était l'Azerbaïjan occidentale que
yeréan et le lac svane appartenait à
l'Arménie que le sunnic le sud de
l'Arménie appartenait n'est à
l'Azerbaïjan et donc Ali considè que
l'Arménie l'Arménie est une province de
l'Azerbaidjan c'est l' sarrêa pas le
risque c'est ça il s'arrêtera pas vous
savez pourquoi il ne s'arrêtera pas
parce qu'en fait le le le projet du
tandem Turquie Azerbaïdjan qui est un
vieux projet c'est de reconstituer un
empire panturque c'est une continuité
territoriale entre la Turquie
l'Azerbaïdjan et un certain nombre de
républiques turcophone d'Asie centrale
pour recréer un empire panturque c'est
une politique néo
de la part d'Erdogan suivi par alief et
donc je sa pas donc la Turquie joue un
rôle important mais la Turquie est le
sponsor de de l'azeran pendant la guerre
des des 44 jours la Turquie a
immédiatement envoyé 80 experts à Bakou
pour piloter la guerre elle a envoyé
1200 soldats d'élite habitué à combattre
en montagne et elle a envoyé
2500 mercenaires djihadiste syrien
supplétif de l'armée turque et donc la
Turquie est pleinement engagé au côté de
l'Azerbaidjan et c'est la Turquie qui
dirige en fait cette ces ces manœuvres
contre contre l'Arménie comment on met
un coup d'arrêt à tout ça enfin le le le
ce qui se passe au carabach est une
chose mais le il est difficilement
imaginable que le conflit se poursuivre
sur le sol arménien ce serait plus du
tout la même donne mais pourquoi ce
serait imaginable le président Aliev a
bien compris aujourd'hui que la
communauté internationale n'était prête
à n'était pas prête à agir militair
serait l'agression d' un État souverain
directement mais invasion la situation
serait autre mais en mai 2021 déjà le
territoire de l'Arménie a été agressé
puisqueaujourd'hui l'Azerbaidjan occupe
une petite partie du territoire arméen
mais occupe tout de même une partie du
territoire arménien il y a eu deux
attaques deux attaques militaires contre
l'Arménie depuis novembre 2020 est-ce
que vous avez vu la communauté
internationale agir assez signif assez
significativement pour impressionner le
président
azerbaidjanais un mot sur Ruben
vardagnan qui est un ancien ministre du
hautkarabak qui a été arrêté est-ce
queaujourd'hui vous avez ces nouvell on
n pas de ses nouvelles on sait qu'il est
dans une prison à Moscou euh à Moscou
pardon on sait qu'il est dans une prison
à Bacou excusez-moi euh il est il n'est
pas seul il est avec lui un général
arménien qui s'appelle David Manouan il
y a un autre militaire arménien qui
s'appelle menat Gagnan et puis l'ancien
ministre des Affaires étrangères David
babayan a été également arrêté donc il y
a eu plusieurs arrestations de offici
duab vous avez parlé d'enlèvement à un
moment il est-ce qu'il y en a vous venez
d'en citer plusieurs il y en a il y en a
eu d'autres est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
d'autres gens qui sont
dét on craint qu'il y en ait d'autres
effectivement il y a eu des enlèvements
dans la population également pour
augmenter le nombre d'otages euh arm des
otages avoir des otages à des
prisonniers de guerre des otages pour
monayer en fait les otages de de la de
la guerre des 44 jours n'ont pas tous
été libérés alors que dans le dans le
l'accord de paix du 9 novembre il avait
été décidé que les otages seraient
libérés d'un côté comme de l'autre
l'Arménie a libéré tous les prisonniers
de guerre immédiatement d'ailleurs vous
avez lancé un appel à Emmanuel Macron
euh pour la libération de Rubel
vardagnan est-ce que cet appel a été
entendu que vous a dit le chef de l'État
je je les équipes de l'Élysée avec qui
nous sommes en contact ont bien
conscience effectivement il faut prendre
en compte cette dimension euh jben vagan
et les trois autres personnes qui sont
arrêtées sont dans une situation
extrêmement dangereuse on imagine bien
de quelle manière l'Azerbaïjan peut se
comporter avec des prisonnier de guerre
on a très peur on a très peur
l'Azerbaïdjan a déjà indiqué qu'il
serait en 4 mois en détention préventive
et qu'il risqué 14 ans de prison la
sentence est dite ça y est le jugement
est donné 14 ans de prison pour Ruben
bartanian et ses camarades et donc il
faut faire quelque chose là aussi il
faut avoir le courage mais la France va
agir Emmanuel Macron vous a dit que la
France AG demand je je nous l'a pas dit
mais on demande à Emmanuel Macron
demande à la communauté internationale
de tout mettre en œuvre pour la
libération effectivement de jouben
vartagan et de ses cam
au-delà du du gouvernement au-delà des
états au-delà de tout ce qu'on vient
d'évoquer comment est-ce que les
Français les Françaises individuellement
peuvent ou pas aider l'Arménie
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
concrètement mais je crois qu'il faut
mettre la pression sur toute le
personnel politique les maires les
députés les sénateurs pour que la
pression remonte et qu'il y ait un
véritable élan de l'opinion publique en
faveur des Arméniens en faveur de
l'avenir des Arméniens il faut sauver
les Arméniens il faut sauver le
haut-karabak nous ne pouvons pas nous
résoudre que l'Azerbaïdjan prenne le
haut-karabak les Arméniens du
Haut-Karabakh qui ont fui la terreur
azerbaïdjanaise pourrait retourner
habiter sur place vous croyez encore un
retour pour vous c'est pas un exode sans
retour non ils pourraient retourner dans
leur maison ils pourraient retourner sur
leur sur le dans leur pays ils habitent
là-bas depuis 2500 ans les Arméniens si
la si la communauté internationale
mettait en place un dispositif de
sécurité il faut le faire il ne faut pas
valider ces crimes de l'Azerbaïjan
l'Azerbaïdjan est une dictature si on
valide ce CRIM de cette dictature on
donne le feu vert aux autres dictatures
et on donne le feu vert au crimes futur
et le futur c'est effectivement
l'agression de l'Arménie donc ce que
vous demandez c'est la la le la la mise
en place d'une force d'interposition il
faut une force d'interposition oh il y a
une délégation de l'ONU qui est allé sur
place on a vu hier et avant-hier il y a
plus personne pour sauver qui et vous
savez quoi Jean-Christophe buisson donc
rédacteur en chef adjoint du figar
magazine indiqué dans un tweet hier que
en fait c c cette délégation de l'ONU
est composée de turc d'azerbaïjanais et
de Russes et de
pakistanaisci merci beaucoup Fran papas
merci d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
et d'être venu nous raconter ce qui se
passe là-bas évidemment c'est à la Une
de West France l'exode des Arméniens du
ha Caraba c'est à la Une de votre
journal Stéphane merci à tous les de
pass au club des territoires